britney spears instagram got a new
update on wednesday
posting this caption apologizing for
pretending like she's been
okay it follows the pop icons bombshell
testimony on wednesday
where she said she was lying about being
okay for the past
two years on thursday brittany's account
shared a new post
seemingly about the previous day's
revelations the post read
i don't want people to think my life is
perfect because it's definitely not
at all and if you have read anything
about me in the news this week
you obviously really know now it's not i
apologize for pretending like i've been
okay the past two years i did it because
of my pride
and i was embarrassed to share what
happened to me
there was also an explanation for the
image posted with her caption
which is a quote from albert einstein
that reads if you want your children to
be intelligent
read them fairy tales if you want them
to be more intelligent
read them more fairy tales the account
elaborated
believe it or not pretending that i'm
okay has actually helped
so i decided to post this quote today
because by golly if you're going through
hell
i feel like instagram has helped me have
a cool outlet to share my presence
existence and to simply feel like i
matter despite what i was going through
and hey it worked so i've decided to
start reading more fairy tales
fans have expressed concern that
britney's instagram account isn't
actually run by brittany herself
a sentiment echoed by samantha stark the
director of the new york times explosive
documentary
framing britney spears what do you
think's happening with her social media
because
there was that comment that you know
i i don't know it's hard because i i do
not think her social media is her after
hearing that because it sounds nothing
like what i heard today and what i heard
today was the real britney spears
around the same time as the post on
brittany's account her boyfriend sam
askari
shared these videos where the couple
appear to be on a private plane
while having plenty of fun with
instagram filters
if you have i ever told you i love
broccoli
that's so stupid on wednesday
sam was seen wearing a free britney
t-shirt leading up to her impassioned
speech
where britney expressed many of her
frustrations to the los
angeles court in the pursuit of ending
her years years-long conservatorship
i think britney wanted the public to
hear what she's been going through she
kept referencing like speaking to the
media
but then she said you know what this is
my chance right now to tell the world so
i think britney's platform for this was
not just the judge
certainly she wanted this judge to hear
but i think she wanted the whole world
to hear
what she was saying the court is always
after the best interests
of the conservative and so brittany
would just have to
explain why it's in her best interest to
end this
and that she is in full control of her
life and that
she can make these important decisions
without the help of someone else in her
life
that has control of it
you